it's easy for leaders to ask their
subordinates a lot of questions the
trick is to ask the right questions
after the disaster at the Bay of Pigs in
April 1961 it took President Kennedy a
few days to go beyond the simple
question of why the CIA had fed him so
much faulty intelligence
finally he asked the right question
why had he been foolish enough to
believe the plan Richard Bissell and the
others at the CIA had offered him
to Red Fae an old friend from their days
in the Navy during the Pacific War
the president shared his belated
realization
that the CIA had set him up
now in retrospect he told Faye about a
week after the botched Invasion I know
damn well that they didn't have any
intention of giving me the straight word
on this thing they just thought that if
we got involved in the thing that I
would have to say go ahead you can throw
all our forces in there and just move
into Cuba
it was too late to salvage anything from
the disaster and it was in politic for
the young leader to start pointing the
finger of blame at others but at least
John Kennedy knew now that his big
mistake was in trusting the intelligence
Community to play it straight with him
that raised the next important question
whom could he Trust
he had lost faith in the Joint Chiefs of
Staff despite all the rows of colorful
ribbons on their chest the big military
brass had seemed to acquiesce in the
cia's plans from the start raising a few
objections as Kennedy complained in
private those sons of [ __ ] with all
the fruit salad just sat there nodding
saying it would work
even his supposedly brilliant Secretary
of Defense Robert McNamara had been
misled
the cost of failure was seriously
understated recalled McNamara in his
oral history for the Kennedy Library
because it was believed that in the
event of failure the invading Force
could escape to the hills to carry on
successful Guerrilla operations
and the price of failure therefore was
thought to be small the price of failure
of course turned out to be tremendous
Kennedy didn't think he could risk
another failure like this one again
almost instinctively he quickly
tightened the circle of those around him
Whose advice he did trust most notably
his loyal assistant Ted Sorensen and his
brother Robert Kennedy
he even toyed with the notion of moving
Bobby from the justice department to
head the CIA
so alarmed was he by the duplicity of
Alan Dulles and Richard Bissell
but perhaps realizing that Bobby was no
better informed on the subject than he
was
the president turned Elsewhere for
private advice on how to handle the
intelligence community
and the military
he reached beyond the usual advisors in
his own Administration to a few
Washington veterans whose experience and
knowledge were widely esteemed
Clark Clifford the ultimate Democratic
party Insider who seemed to know
everyone worth knowing in Washington was
called to the White House to share his
wisdom on the best way for the leader of
the Free World to avoid being duped
again
he was as serious as I have ever seen
him said Clifford of JFK recalling our
meeting in an oral history from 1974. of
the Bay of Pigs disaster the president
said that he probably would not survive
another catastrophe of that kind
Kennedy added this has come early I
would hope that I could live it down but
it's going to be difficult to do
he recruited Clifford and a few other
trusted advisors to determine ways of
improving the Gathering of intelligence
and how it was shared within the
government
I have to have the best possible
intelligence he told Clifford bluntly
just as urgently he needed an
experienced military man at his side
who would help him avoid making another
blunder like invading Cuba
in effect he wanted his own personal
four-star general in the White House
and he got him in the person of Maxwell
Taylor recently retired as Chief of
Staff of the army and a highly decorated
wartime commander of the 101st Airborne
Division not to mention a former
superintendent of West Point
ironically the president who had
complained in the aftermath of the Bay
of Pigs all my life I've known better
than to depend on the experts
was now surrounding himself with more
experts just better ones in his
estimation
the key word here is estimation his
process of figuring out whose expertise
he could trust
because he didn't trust his current
Chiefs he simply went around them and
put Maxwell Taylor on a different level
returning him to active duty and giving
him at first the new title of military
representative of the president
before elevating him later to Chairman
of the joint Chief's staff
the service chiefs were not happy
Arleigh Burke a legendary Admiral who
was chief of Naval operations at the
time thought that JFK's new
Administration was full of quote rank
amateurs who simply didn't understand
Washington well enough to govern the
country effectively he was from the old
school and blamed the whole disaster of
the Cuban Invasion on the CIA pitching
their plan directly to the president and
leaving everyone else out of the loop
quote there were no normal channels of
communication we're called Admiral Berg
in 1967 and so nobody ever knew who was
doing what
the CIA was running the operation and
The Joint Chiefs were told over and over
and over again dozens of times it is not
a military operation
impatient and ambitious Admiral Burke
said the Kennedy people quote cut
through what they thought was red tape
but what they thought was red tape was
standard procedures for doing things
and so immediately there was chaos
because nobody knew who was doing
anything
the president in a very short while
would call up one man ask his opinion
and other people who were responsible
for that activity would not be called
the result was that all this
misunderstanding and confusion ended in
a mistake so bad at the Bay of Pigs that
JFK was desperate for the kind of
clarity that old hands like Clark
Clifford and Maxwell Taylor seemed
willing to offer
ultimately the real Clarity had to come
from the president himself
and he knew it he wanted another chance
very soon to prove that he was not an
amateur that he could lead and do it
decisively
he got his chance less than two months
after the Bay of Pigs when he stepped
onto the world stage in Vienna Austria
for a summit with another old school
leader but of the Communist Variety in
this case
Nikita Khrushchev
not surprisingly the Soviet leader
welcomed this meeting as a chance to
bully the inexperienced Young American
president who looked so vulnerable after
the blunder in Cuba
the two men were a study and contrast
Khrushchev short and stout Kennedy toll
and slender the Russian a crusty
Survivor of Stalin's intrigues and
purges in his 60s an old party war horse
with no sense of style and without a
single suit that really fit him and JFK
and elegant son of capitalist privilege
with a sophisticated glamorous wife who
towered over Khrushchev and his
distinctly unglamorous spouse
and none of it seemed to matter to the
Soviet leader who thought that all the
geopolitical advantages were his
he was wrong
the Soviet economy was weak his military
looked better on paper than in reality
and the global influence of Communism
waxed in Wayne depending on the quality
of the latest propaganda campaigns
the one thing he did have going for him
was nuclear weapons and enough Bluster
to make the West fear that he might just
use them
before he landed in Vienna JFK was given
some advice on how to handle Khrushchev
but this time the advice was excellent
and the source Avril Harriman actually
knew what he was talking about
a former ambassador to the Soviet Union
he had been at the big wartime
conferences in Russia with Churchill and
Roosevelt and he had a good
understanding of criminal and politics
yet to Kennedy who was relying on him as
a diplomatic troubleshooter his advice
must have sounded a little frivolous
Harriman told him not to take Khrushchev
too seriously
here's what the seasoned Ambassador said
about the Soviet leader don't let him
rattle you he'll try to Rattle you and
frighten you but don't pay any attention
to that turn him aside gently and don't
try for too much remember that he's just
as scared as you are he is very aware of
his peasant origins of the contrast
between Mrs Khrushchev and Jackie
it was Sound Advice Harriman understood
that Khrushchev was not as cunning as
Stalin and did not have as firm a grip
on power
Khrushchev was a Survivor who had
learned long ago to push his luck only
so far in the deadly political games of
Stalin's Russia and then to pull back
before someone called his bluff or
raised the stakes too high
Harriman summed up Khrushchev this way
quote his style will be to attack and
then see if he can get away with it
laugh about it don't get into a fight
rise above it
but the Bay of Pigs had undermined JFK's
confidence and he did let Khrushchev get
under his skin
over two days in early June 1961 the two
leaders met for several hours arguing
over nuclear testing disarmament
and the West's access to Berlin which
lay inside communist East Germany
the Soviet leader was contentious on all
these issues resisting any proposals of
cooperation between the two sides
returning to Stalin's old Playbook
Khrushchev knew he could rattle the West
by threatening to isolate the French
British and American enclaves in Berlin
as the Soviets had done in their
blockade of the city in 1948
Kennedy was taken aback by the Hostile
response to his repeated efforts to seek
a compromise
he tried to be charming and witty but
nothing seemed to work
during one break when Khrushchev
explained that he was wearing two medals
for the linen Peace Prize on his jacket
a frustrated JFK fired back I hope you
get to keep them
there was nothing clever or witty about
Khrushchev he was coarse and direct the
Urbane American president had little
experience dealing with men as crude and
outspoken as cruise ship who didn't have
much respect for anyone he didn't fear
he would have tried to intimidate any
adversary whether it happened to be
Kennedy or a Republican president he
hated Richard Nixon with whom he had
famously debated at a U.S exhibition in
Moscow in 1959. as he later complained
to an American visitor quote Mr Nixon
reminds me of a herring salesman who
would sell spoiled Herring as the real
thing
at the end of The Summit Kennedy thought
that his efforts were a complete failure
that the Soviet leader had treated him
with contempt and was determined to
cause him more trouble in the months
ahead
I've got two problems he confided
privately afterward first to figure out
why he did it and in such a hostile way
and second to figure out what we can do
about it
I think the first part is pretty easy to
explain I think he did it because of the
Bay of Pigs I think he thought that
anyone who was so young and
inexperienced as to get into that mess
could be taken and anyone who got into
it and didn't see it through
had no guts
so he just beat the hell out of me
other observers were not so pessimistic
about Kennedy's performance they thought
that he had held his ground well and
that Khrushchev was more than a little
impressed by the young president's
toughness and intelligence
in an interview given to the Kennedy
Library in 1966 the American ambassador
to the Kremlin at the time of the summit
Llewellyn Thompson recalled that
Khrushchev quote made quite clear that
he in a way envied the president at that
time it looked as though Kennedy had
many years ahead of him he envied his
Youth and as I say I think he quite
respected his ability and his grasp of
these questions
President Kennedy had spent a lot of
time discussing with me and others
Soviet Affairs and he had done a lot of
reading and was I think quite
knowledgeable
I imagine this impressed Khrushchev
but whatever favorable impression he may
have had of the younger leader the old
veteran of the Soviet state was still
going to make trouble whenever and
wherever he might testing Kennedy's
resolve and trying to get away with as
much as he could
in fact it took the Communists little
more than two months after the Vienna
Summit to launch their most provocative
plan for Berlin dividing the city with a
concrete barrier between the East and
West sections
the Berlin Wall as it came to be known
was harder on the people in the
Communist Zone because it was meant to
stop the loss of brains and talent
fleeing to freedom in the West
by some estimates more than two and a
half million people had left East Berlin
in just a 12-year period leading up to
1961.
the wall trapped the remaining
population and quickly became the most
reviled symbol of Oppression during the
Cold War
indeed in the long term building the
wall was a greater blunder for the
Communists than the Bay of Pigs was for
the U.S at least 130 people were killed
trying to escape over the wall and the
Damage Done to the international image
of the Communist cause
was devastating
the failure at the Vienna Summit was not
Kennedy's but khrushchevs who
overestimated his own position and who
couldn't resist the chance to undermine
this new leader in the West
although it was alarming in its brutal
appearance building the Berlin Wall was
itself a sign of weakness on the Soviet
side
a recognition not only of their failures
to Rally East berliners to the Communist
cause
but also I Surrender of sorts to the
West
how so before construction of the wall
began on August the 13th 1961.
the overwhelming worry in America was
that the Soviets would invade West
Berlin and eliminate it as a Haven of
Freedom inside East Germany
instead they built the wall which is bad
enough for the people living behind it
but it was not a direct assault on West
Berlin
if the Soviets had ever been tempted to
launch such an assault
John Kennedy took a dramatic step to
dissuade them in a nationally televised
address to the American people the
previous month on July 25th
he looked tired and pale on television
and was under great strain not only
because of the international tensions
but also because he had suffered a
setback in his long struggle with his
health shortly after his return from
Vienna he was on crutches again taking
more medications that were good for him
to control the pain in his back
but his intense somber expression at
times during the address gave his words
more weight he was deadly serious about
stopping any invasion of West Berlin and
made it clear that he would retaliate
against such an action with all the
force at his command
these are the words from Kennedy that
Khrushchev could not afford to ignore
we do not want to fight but we have
fought before
those who threaten to unleash the forces
of War on a dispute over West Berlin
should recall the words of the ancient
philosopher a man who causes fear cannot
be free from Fear
in other words Mr Khrushchev it's time
to stop pushing your luck and pull back
before it's too late
that was the kind of message the Kremlin
understood
three weeks later the wall went up as a
face-saving tactic for the belligerent
Soviets a provocative act designed to
look aggressive without unleashing as
Kennedy put it the forces of War
the two leaders would soon lock horns
again during the worst episode of the
Cold War the Cuban Missile Crisis of
October 1962 where misunderstandings on
both sides would bring the world to the
brink of nuclear war
we will study the frightening Arc of
that crisis in the next lecture but for
now it's important to point out that
instead of just rattling his sword candy
also had less confrontational responses
to the Communist challenge in his
Arsenal
he was prepared to do all the usual
things to build up defenses and resist
aggression
but he also had the imagination to see
that the West
could counteract the Soviet threat in
less dangerous ways than say a military
confrontation over Berlin
in keeping with the aspirational tone of
his inaugural address
he wanted to showcase the best of
America in contrast to the worst
excesses of Soviet tyranny what he
offered first was the Peace Corps an
unarmed Army of volunteers willing to
show how modern America could offer a
helping hand to the rest of the world
his second step was to demonstrate the
full measure of American ingenuity
by starting a race to reach the Moon by
the end of the decade
which enabled competition between the
two superpowers
but without the threat of War
it seemed an impossible goal at the time
and many people thought it was a wasted
effort what was the point they asked
what was a moon landing supposed to
prove
NASA had been set up in the Eisenhower
Administration to explore space
technology but Eisenhower himself
believed that sending astronauts to the
Moon would only be a quote stunt saying
that he quote couldn't care less whether
a man ever reached the Moon
in any case America lagged behind the
Soviets when the Space Race began
first in October 1957 when Sputnik 1 was
launched then again in April 1961 when
Cosmonaut Yuri Gagarin had become the
first human in outer space orbiting the
Earth in his capsule lostock won
the best that the United States could do
in response was to launch its own
satellite into space in 1958. then send
astronaut Alan Shepard on a brief
sub-orbital space flight on May the 5th
1961. it was a major achievement for the
American space program but in
photographs taken at the White House
when the launch was televised
you can see the apprehension on the
faces of Kennedy and his staff
they look anything but confident in
those pictures
and in fact Kennedy had long harbored
doubts about the value of the Space
Program
but Shepherd's success changed
everything
such was the relief when his capsule
returned safely to Earth that the
astronaut was treated to an enormous
outpouring of adulation by the American
public
the President also gave him a hero's
welcome at the White House
it was hard to imagine how this first
foray into space would result in a moon
landing for American astronauts in just
eight years
but that's what John Kennedy promised
only 20 days after Alan Shepard's flight
addressing a special session of Congress
the president made one of his most
famous pronouncements when he declared
quote I believe that this nation should
commit itself to achieving the goal
before this decade is out of Landing a
man on the moon and returning him safely
to the Earth
amazingly in the film of his speech we
can see that the members of Congress
greeted the statement with little
enthusiasm so Fantastical did the notion
of going to the Moon seem in those days
there is just a brief sound of a few
Representatives starting to clap and
then silence
my guess is that a lot of those
politicians thought that they were
listening to a wild campaign promise
that would never be fulfilled in their
lifetimes
which is why the speech is so thrilling
to watch now
we know that Kennedy's promise was
fulfilled and we know that it sparked a
huge technological Revolution that not
only changed our relationship to space
but also our lives on this planet
we cannot overestimate the profound
impact of Kennedy's challenge especially
when we consider how outrageously
ambitious it seemed in 1961.
he was taken advantage of a moment in
time to launch a massive change that
would influence events for decades to
come which is surely the kind of Grand
Vision we expect from a great leader
whatever other faults that leader may
have
after the embarrassing setback in Cuba
the previous month Kennedy wanted a
reset for his presidency
he had his eye on big changes and wanted
to avoid if at all possible getting
bogged down in Endless conflicts or
Petty disputes over small things
the basic dynamic in his presidency was
the ever-present struggle between his
cautious side and his desire to go big
and bold
with his speech on May 25th he went so
big and so bold that he left many in his
own party bewildered
as for the Republicans many of them
thought he was being hopelessly
unrealistic and quickly seized on the
predictable charge that he was proposing
billions for quote Pie in the Sky
spending as the Republican National
chairman Senator thruston Morton of
Kentucky put it in the New York Times
in purely political terms it just didn't
make much sense for Kennedy to go so far
out on a limb and promise the Moon
in the short term it didn't change much
at home or abroad and the Soviets didn't
seem any more impressed by his Moon talk
than the Republicans were
but it made all the difference to his
legacy that he made this promise
it was rooted both in his faith in
America's technological potential and in
his recognition that the times demanded
action that would result in a surge of
progress that could transform the nation
and the world
you don't get much more forward-looking
than Kennedy does In this lesser-known
passage from his speech to Congress
now is the time to take longer strides
time for a great new American Enterprise
time for this nation to take a clearly
leading role in space achievement which
in many ways May hold the key to our
future on Earth
promising the moon was the greatest
moment of Kennedy's presidency it was
transformative enduring and politically
courageous perhaps even more impressive
it was unexpected but the rocky start
that marked his administration in the
first half of 1961 and the devious
intrigues of both Kennedy's own
intelligence community and the Soviets
gave him the impetus to try something
radically different
which is another sign of great
leadership the willingness to change
course and Forge A New Path
it also allowed Kennedy to find a better
way of employing his vice president
on April 20th only a few days after Yuri
gagarin's space flight
Kennedy sent an Urgent Message to Lyndon
Johnson about the potential for
accelerating and expanding America's
Space Program
why did he go to Johnson for this
when he was a majority leader everyone
in the Senate knew that Johnson was
passionate about space exploration he
had helped to set up a National Space
Council in the late 1950s and JFK had
made him its chairman one of only two
committees he had been assigned to by
the new president
eager to have something substantial to
occupy him as vice president
Johnson would make the Space Program his
special area of interest and he began in
April by urging Kennedy to pursue a
moonshot
always competitive in nature Johnson Saw
the space race as a way to beat the
Soviets without having to fight them
in the eyes of the world he said first
in space means first period second in
space is second in everything
perhaps the most important Johnson knew
how to get the money from Congress to
fund an ambitious Space Program he
understood that a large Hall of cash for
projects in southern states would be
irresistible to his closest Senate
colleagues which helps to explain how so
much of the program ended up operating
out of places like Houston and
Huntsville Alabama home of NASA's
Marshall space flight center
after Alan Shepard's successful flight
candy couldn't resist TC Johnson quote
nobody knows that the vice president is
the chairman of the space Council but if
that flight had been a flop I guarantee
you that everybody would have known that
you were the chairman
overhearing the Joe Newton Meadow the
head of the Federal Communications
Commission added Mr president if the
flight had been a flop the vice
president would have been the next
astronaut
only a week after giving his speech on
May 25th Kennedy was on his way to meet
with Khrushchev in Vienna he was in the
middle of some of the most demanding
months of any presidency and he was
facing obstacles in all directions
before and end domestic it is no wonder
that his health took a turn for the
worst that summer he was besieged by
difficulties of extraordinary
proportions and the American public had
no idea of how precarious his health was
he made a recovery of course but there
were even greater challenges ahead and
he would need all his strength to
confront them as we shall see in our
next lecture on the pivotal year of
1962.